well excessively long lineups and delays
continue to plague many airports across
this country especially toronto's
pearson international staff shortages
are said to contribute to this but the
canadian airports council says the other
main reasons are the cumbersome covid19
protocols the random testing and health
questions for example that is why they
want them scrapped as for the other
requirement the travel vaccine mandate
well the council isn't calling for its
removal but has been reported as saying
it's a discussion worth having
so let's continue this discussion
joining us now with more is infectious
diseases physician dr suman chakrabarti
doctor welcome back to the program
good morning izzy so let's begin with
the covet health protocols at the
airport the airport's council as i
mentioned is asking for their removal
from a business perspective of course is
resulting in a lot of frustration a lot
of inefficiencies
and then there's the medical perspective
they say given the high vaccination rate
they're not necessary would you agree
uh i would totally agree with that look
we're in a different phase of the
pandemic where we have to remember in
canada we have greater than 90 of people
on the ground who are vaccinated and
let's not forget that the people who are
unvaccinated are largely at this point
immune having been exposed to the virus
so when we look at
these measures what are we actually
doing i don't think we're actually doing
anything that's medically useful and
it's obviously causing a lot of delay in
travel making travel very difficult and
ironically when you have a lot of people
who are crowded together you're
increasing transmission anyway so i
think that we really need to re-examine
this and scrap a lot of this theater so
let's talk about the vaccine the travel
vaccine mandate and this in many ways is
contributing to this with the arrive can
app and the questions that come with it
at the time when it was implemented it
was because of the high cases and it was
also the justification was to reduce
transmission as you know science evolves
what is the science saying now
yeah this is another thing that i think
is important to change as well is that
the vaccine is amazing at stopping
severe disease that's one thing that we
know but unfortunately we're seeing that
it doesn't do very good at reducing
transmission especially on a population
scale so when you when you can't
actually reduce transmission you're
basically now just keeping people who
are unable to get or who don't want to
get vaccinated unable to get vaccinated
off a plane for no good medical reason
and i think that's discriminatory so i
think at this point especially in the
new phase of the pandemic the vast vast
majority of us are protected i think
it's time to now drop that mandate and
allow people who haven't gotten the
vaccine to now board planes and trains
to be able to go see their loved ones
and i'm sure you can appreciate this is
a controversial opinion and there are a
couple ways of looking at that right uh
when people see the waning efficacy data
to even the three shots that we've seen
some would argue that look
perhaps they're ineffective in the long
term not worth it others would say this
is the time to have a regular booster
dose
what would you what's your opinion on
that yeah this is something that we
don't actually have a lot of data on it
it's important to note that even with
the third dose we do see that it
benefits especially those who are older
than the age of about 60 or so and
certain immune compromising conditions
but we don't have good randomized
prospective data showing that it's
something that's good for the entire
population let alone the fourth dose so
i think it's important for us now we're
in a new phase of the pandemic the
emergency is now behind us but it's
obviously still here we need to continue
to gather good high quality data before
we make uh you know broad type of
recommendations for the population on
immunity is that we're now seeing that
there's certain populations that
certainly we must target much more than
others at the time as well it's been
described to me this was to accelerate
if not encourage uh vaccine uptake did
it have that effect
maybe for the first little bit it did
i think there's no question that
mandates do do something initially up
front but in the long term did it really
did it really get to the populations at
this point we're not wanting to get the
vaccine i don't think so i think that we
have to remember that from previous
vaccine campaigns uh the max that we
ever got was something like 40 when you
look at things like influenza so to get
you know 90 91 percent of people on the
ground and if you look at high-risk
populations in canada it's something
more like 97 to 98
we did a wonderful job of getting people
vaccinated but let's not forget that
people who haven't been vaccinated also
have a significant amount of immunity
due to uh exposure so we're in a very
very good place i don't think we need to
coerce people to get vaccinated i think
now it's time for us to move forward and
realize that as a population we're very
very well protected against sars kobe
too i have literally just a few seconds
but some would say that this is perhaps
an irresponsible time are you confident
that if this were to be lifted that
there wouldn't be a high uptick in
numbers
we might see some uptick but look this
is not where the majority of
transmission is happening in travel it's
happening in households and workplaces
so definitely i think now is the time i
don't think that we're going to have
anything that makes it for example
hospitals to be overflowed we're in a
good spot it's time to lift these
restrictions we have to leave it there
dr suman chakravarti we appreciate that
thank you sir